Kim Kardashian breaks her silence amid
her ex Kanye West's anti-semitic
comments on Monday the reality star and
Mama 4 spoke out on Twitter writing
quote hate speech is never okay or
excusable I stand together with the
Jewish community and call on the
terrible violence and hateful rhetoric
towards them to come to an immediate end
Kim's message comes just hours after her
sister Chloe voiced her support too she
shared this message originally posted by
Jessica Seinfeld author and wife of
comedian Jerry Seinfeld who wrote quote
if you don't know what to say you can
just say this in your feed more members
of the famous family followed suit
including Kylie Kendall and Kris Jenner
who later shared the same message on
their own insta stories but the
Kardashians aren't the only ones
condemning Kanye's remarks stars like
Haley Bieber Chrissy Teigen Carrie
Washington Vanessa engines Amy Schumer
and Kimora Lee Simmons showed their
support too while Michael Rappaport went
in on Kanye on his YouTube channel
imagine what this [ __ ] guy has done
to Kim Kardashian and I'll say this that
and the third about Kim Kardashian but
I'm team Kardashian imagine being
married to this guy there's so many
worst things going on in the world a
billionaire got divorced from his wife
with his beautiful kids
that are well taken care of and you need
the world to babysit you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] to tell grow the
[ __ ] up this all comes after yay wrote
that he intended to go death Con 3 on
Jewish people a post that led to his
social media accounts being suspended
the rapper later doubled down delivering
an anti-semitic rant in a since deleted
episode of the drink Champs podcast
the Jewish media was pushing the
narrative off the White live White lives
matter t-shirt that I didn't love black
people and I came off and I came back
and I was like no [ __ ] the Jewish media
and in the days that followed Vogue and
Balenciaga cut ties with Kanye as did
CAA the talent agency that represents
him film and television Studio MRC
announced they're shelving a completed
documentary about the Grammy winner but
the big question remains will he be
dropped by Adidas the company that
produces and distributes his Yeezy
sneakers
the thing about it me and Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic and
they can't drop me
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me
now what
now what the apparel giant has
previously said their relationship with
Kanye is under review